حصلت عليها العربيه نات فان اولى
المحاكمات ستتم في مدينه عين العرب كوباني
باعتبار ان معركه القضاء على التنظيم
انطلقت منها ووسط مخاوف امنيه غربيه
متعلقه بخطر اصطياد هروب عناصر تنظيم داعش
في مثلها كذا محاكمات وصفات دبلوماسيون
غربي قرارا الاداره الكرديه بالمفاجئ
معتبرا ان هناك فرق بين الاحتجاز
والمحاكمه
اقرض سوريا يحاكمون عناصر داعش تحتجز قصد
عشره الاف مقاتل ينتمون لداعش في 20 مركز
احتجاز ينتم هؤلاء العناصر الى 60 جنسيه
بين المحتجزين الف اجنبي يوجد 51 الف فرد
من عائله داعش معظمهم من النساء والاطفال
في مخيم الهول الاسبوع الماضي اعلنت قصه
انها سلمت 50 عراقيا من داعش الى بغداد
كما اعادت 170 عراقيه كانوا يعيشون في
مخيم الهول
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من صالح مسلم
رئيس المشترك لحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
اهلا بك استاذ صالح ومن باريس جون بيرمي
الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المسلحه اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من باريس
معك
في الواقع سؤال المطروح مع اعلان
قصد البدء بالتحضير لمحاكمه الدواعش سؤال
مطروح اين هي دول الغربيه من كل هذا لانه
قصد كانت اعلنت في السابق وكانت وجهت
نداءات لدول الغربيه بتسلم مواطنيها هل
يمكن القول بان الغرب تخلى عن مواطنه حتى
وان كانوا دواعش ولكن هذا الغرب الذي
نتحدث عنه هو الغرب الذي كان يروج لمنطق
الحريات وحقوق المواطنين خاصه
مساء الخير لا شك ان هذا الطرح لقصد ياتي
بسياق معين مع عوده الدوله السوريه الى
الاسره العربيه ومع
بعض وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بانفاق
ملايين في المنطقه فكان
قصاد
احست بان الوقت مناسب
لاعاده طرح هذا الملف الثقيل والصعب على
الطاوله فهناك في نظري
افهم كلام حضرتك هل تشير حضرتك بان قصد
تتعمد طرح مثل هكذا ملف للحصول على اموال
امريكيه
لمحاكمتهم لماذا ترك الغرب مقاتلي لدى قصد
خليني اطرح هذا السؤال للسيد صالح سيد
صالح هل انتهت كل الحلول مع الغرب ليتوجه
قصد لمحاكمه هؤلاء وكيف ستتم المحاكمات
يعني هل يمكن القول بان ملف ارجاع هؤلاء
للغرب قد اغلقت تماما
سيدتي تحياتي لك ولجميع مشاهديك الكرام
بالنسبه لموضوع داعش طبعا كما تعلمون ان
هذا الموضوع يعني تم القضاء الجغرافيا على
داعش في 2019 ونحن الان في
2023 منذ اليوم الاول نحن ناشدنا جميع
الدول وقلنا لهم بان هذه قضيه امميه وقضيه
دوليه ولا تخصنا فقط لان هؤلاء اكثر من
اربعين دوله وهؤلاء معتزون ولكن يبدو انهم
شعروا براحه بانهم هؤلاء مسجون لدى
الاداره الذاتيه الديمقراطيه وهم يقومون
مما يلزم ونحن
لنتركهم يعملون ما يعملون ولكن الحقيقه
ليست كذلك يعني نحن الان نتحدث عن حوالي
اكثر من عشره الاف
داعشه موجودين في السجون واكثر من خمسين
الف مع عوائلهم وا وما الى ذلك هذه القضيه
امميه وقضيه دوليه لانها تخص دول عديده
وقد تشكلت التحال
فا هذه القضيه قضيه دوليه ولكن ضيفي منذ
قليل يقول هو يعترف يقول بانه حقيقه قصد
كانت مشاركه وبقوه في هزيمه داعش ان كان
كذب بطريقه
نهائيه ولكن يقول في المقابل هناك اشارات
او هناك قراءات بان قصد قد تكون تتعامل مع
هذا الملف للضغط بقصد التمويل بقصد اهداف
اخرى ما رايك في هذا الطرح
هذا غير صحيح نحن لا نقبله هناك موضوع يجب
الحل اذا ما لم نقم بذلك فماذا امامنا
النفع نحن نطالب بمحاكمه دوليه وما دام
التحالف الدولي يتشكل لمحاربه داعش فيجب
ان يكون هناك تحالف دولي لمحاكمه هؤلاء
اما الامم المتحده او محكمه دوليه وهذا
نحن عجزنا منذ اربع سنوات اكثر من اربع
سنوات ونحن نطالب من خمس نحن نطالب بان
تهتم الدول بهذا الامم المتحده وكل ماذا
يصل اليه في ايدينا ولكن لم يفعلوا شيئا
ويبدو انهم مرتاحون لهذه الحاله ولكن
نحن من جانبنا يعني نلاقي ضغطا من شعبنا
الشعب يقول هؤلاء حاربون وقتلوا اولادنا
وذبحونا
وارتكبوا جرائم ضد الانسانيه والان انتم
تحتجزونهم وتغذونهم وتحرسونهم وحتى تقدمون
تقدمون لهم جميع الخدمات الصحيه يعني يجب
ان يكون هناك نهايه لهذا الامر ولهذا
تعتقد حضرتك بانه الغرب خذل مواطنيه حتى
وان كانوا دواعش ام ان الغرب خذل قسد خذل
الحكومه الذاتيه في شمال وشرق سوريا
لا اعتقد انهم طرحوا او ناقشوا
يشعرون براحه لانهم لا يريدون ان يعودوا
هؤلاء الاوطانهم لا ربما يخذلون
المواطنيهم او يخذلون بالنسبه لنا طبعا
نحن نعجزنا عن مخاطبتهم ومطاولتهم بهذا
الامر ولهذا لم يبقى
امر
ونجعله مفتوحه لكل من يريد المساهمه فيه
والاداره ذاتيه الديمقراطيه على فكره انت
تكررين الاداره الكرديه هي ليست كرديه
الديمقراطيه
نعم جميع مشا هي ليست كرديه هذه الاداره
هي التي الان ستقوم بتاسيس يعني صدرت
الاوامر او تعليمات لهيئه العدل لتقوم
باجراءات معينه على ان تكون هذه المحكمه
مفتوحه امام الجميع لكل اعود لتفاصيل هذه
المحاكمه سيد صالح ساعود لتفاصيل لانه
كذلك هناك جدل كبير حول اليات المحاكمه
ولكن كنت تستمع الى ضيف قال بانوا
المنشدات كانت عديده ومن زمن طويل من
الاداره الذاتيه في شمال وشرق سوريا
لمحاوله تسليم المقاتلين الدواعش ولكن هذا
لم يتم
هل تعتقد بان هذا الموضوع بان يبقى
الدواعش في شمال وشرق سوريا اريح للغرب
تصريحاته تتحدث عن الحقوق وعن حقوق الزام
الاكراد بمحاكمه عادله ولكن الفعل يقول
بانهم وكانهم يعني استسهلوا الموضوع
وتركوا هذا الموضوع
للحكومه الذاتيه
اولا اريد ان اذكر ان فرنسا
هي من ضمن قال الضيف الكريم الاربعين
جنسيات التي ينتمي اليها
العناصر داعش السابقين ولكن هناك فرق كبير
بين
فرنسا
مثلا هو ان الدواعش ارتكبوا مجازر لا
سابقه له
لها في العاصمه الفرنسيه
فرنسا تعرف كذلك ما معنى داعش ولكن بغض
النظر عن ذلك
وذكرته من باب
الملاحظه
اجاب وزير العادله الفرنسيه امام المجلس
الشيوخ في شهر اكتوبر الثاني بشكل مفصل
اجابه على اسئله الشيوخ
ولخص الموقف
الفرنسي بكلمات قليله قائلا بان
فرنسا ترفض العوده بالجمله لعناصر داعش
انما تاخذ هناك تصريحات لرئيس ماكرون حدث
فيها عن المحاكمه بمنطق
الحاله بالحاله هذا مفهوم ولكن هذا الحديث
اتذكرها من سنوات لم يتم شيء جديد بخصوصه
بلى هناك
حصل في السنه الماضيه عوده مجموعه من
النساء مع اطفالهن مع اطفالهن صحيح ان
الحكومه الفرنسيه تدرس
الامور فردا فردا او ملفا ملفا وتاخذ بان
الاعتبار فقط الذين يرغبون في العوده الى
فرنسا هناك كثير منهم لا يريدون العوده
الى فرنسا اولا
المجرم ولكن هذا هذا موضوع طويل
نناقشه ربما لاحقا حتى نبقى في جوهر
الموضوع
سؤالي كان هل يريح الغرب اكثر ترك هذه
المساله مساله المحاكمه
للسلطه الذاتيه شمال وشرق سوريا هذا
السؤال نعم ام لا
ليست الامر بهذه البساطه انا متاسف قلت
انما المجرم الفرنسي الذي يبيع المخدرات
في سنغافورها يحاكم في سنغافوره وكيف يمكن
للقضاء الفرنسيين ان يحاكموا على احداث
حدثت في سوريا
والعراق هذا صعب
التصور فيما يخصه او الاولاد هناك ايتام
هناك اولاد
نسبهم
غامد ولكن فرنسا لم تفعل ما فعل مثلا
الدنمارك وبريطانيا العظمى يعني لم تسقط
جنسيههم لبعض عناصر الدواعش بين مع انها
كان هذا مبررا اذا تخلوا عمليه الجنسيه
صحيح اسمح لي فقط لاتفاعل مع حضرتك سيقول
لك بعضهم ربما هذه المقاربه التي قدمتها
ليس الدقيقه ان يحاكم احدهم على بيع
المخدرات في سنغافوره ولكن تعلم حضرتك لما
يحدث ذلك الحكومه الفرنسيه ترسل محامين
وترسل محققين وترسل معه مجموعه للتاكد من
تورطه فيما بعد يحاكم بالطريقه التي يراها
تراها السلطه السنغافوريه مناسبه له ولكن
نحن لما نتابع محاكمه هؤلاء الى حد الان
ليست هناك تقارير تؤكد مثلا تورط من قتل
تورط من سلح تورط منول وكان فرنسا وهذا
كان سؤال في البدايه وكان فرنسا وغيرها من
دول الغرب تخلت عن هذه القضيه تماما ان
كان لك تعليق في خصوص هذه النقطه سيد صالح
[موسيقى]
الذي حدث نحن
تاكدنا هو خلال التحقيقات ان هناك اخرين
قوه خارجيه متورطه هم الذين دفعوا الى
التمرد ونظموا وزودوا بالسلاح وما الى ذلك
وهناك اخطار بان يتم تفكيك هذه السجون لان
هناك من يحاول ان يطلق صراحه فاذا اطلقوا
هم سيعودون مره اخرى الى
اوروبا يعني انهم خطرا عالميا
طالما حضرتك تتحدث عن سجن الصناعه هذا
السجن تذكره لانه كان هناك فيه 11 فرنسي
وبين ليله وضحاها تم
اخذهم من هذا السجن باتجاه العراق نعلم
بانه الاداره الذاتيه شمال شرق سوريا ليست
من او في قانون الذاتي في قانونها ذاتي
ليس هناك حديث يستند على الاعدام ولكن
هؤلاء خرجوا من سجون شمال سوريا واخذوا
بين ليله وضحاها الى العراق وتم حكم
الاعدام فيهم وتم تنفيذ حكم الاعدام 11
فرنسي سؤال مطروح هل ستعتمد
السلطه ذاتيه شمال سوريا مثل هكذا لانه
هناك شكوك في الواقع هناك مخاوف هي تقول
لن اعدم ولكن من يضمن ذلك
يعني مساله الفرنسيين الذين اخذوا للعراق
انا لا لم اسمع بهذا
الفكره تحدث عنه الاعلام كثيرا في 2019
ربما بعد الاطراف مؤكده ونحن هنا لم نسمع
بهذا
الاطلاقا وان
ما لانهم ارتكبوا جرائم في العراق وهذا
شان طبعا التحالف الدولي
والاداره ذاتيه الديمقراطيه وقصد هم الذين
يحرسون هذه السجون بالنسبه للمدنيين كما
ذكرت اشار اليها ضيفكم ايضا نحن
لا نرى شيئا اي طرف يريد ان ياخذ النساء
والاطفال
يجب ان يرضوا طبعا مثل ما قال بالعوده نحن
لا نشترط اي شيء ولا حتى حتى ان بعضهم
عادوا الى بلدان تعرضوا لمحاكمات هناك
بالنسبه للمساجين فلدينا من جرائم هنا
ونحن وجهه نظرنا انهم يجب ان يحاكموا هنا
واذا كانوا يريدون العدل ومحاكمه عادله
وكذا شفافه نحن مستعدون لذلك وبامكان
فرنسا وغير فرنسا ان يرسلوا المحرمين
والقضاه
متابعه طيب هو المفروض كان سنتحدث استاذ
صالح
كان المفروض سنتحدث عن المحاكمه عن
تفاصيلها وكيف ستضمن الحقوق ولكن حتى وان
كان اندواعش ولكن ربما نرجا هذه النقاط
لحلقه اخرى انتهى تماما توقيت هذا الملف
شكرا جزيلا لكم على هذه المشاركه من
الحسكه صالح مسلم رئيس المشترك لحزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي ومن باريس في شؤون
الجماعات المسلحه شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات